bom dia só tá vendo você e aí galera que
assistindo àquela todos como ficou o
acidente era mais uma vez não sei o que
está acontecendo na minha vida eu não
sei o que acontece não porque toda vez
que eu fico sem dormir a minha vida
começa a perder se sentido um sermão que
está acontecendo no sentido das coisas
não sei que estou fazendo até aqui os
carros com as motos as pessoas são como
as pedras e os cachorros o cônjuge e
brincando o bonde quando fica assim é
porque me sinto mais livre sabe eu me
sinto uma pessoa mas liberta se eu me
sinto a dor a aventura ainda aventureira
darão muito idiota do lixo de encontrar
o mar
não sei se estou vindo marca jb tomar na
hora tu é dormente a gente encontrar um
hipopótamo que eu estou vendo com foto
o hipopótamo tomatada prisão todinha e
ela não ficar as senhoras são reflexos
das pessoas à sociedade esse desenho
nunca que vem estamos e fazer alguma
coisa mesmo ele vai ensinar meu filho
fica mais [ __ ] em casa eu acho que
dora é um desenho feito para deixar a
criança mais aguardada acaba se atrasar
eu galera onde assistir um filme eu acho
mais neve e se veste de estragar edição
dois velhos são paulo com a fugir da
cadeia na área cá eles fogem existem é
cara ele ganha a vida fugindo de capeta
quer dizer é pago para mostrar o quanto
as prisões não são sempre os 65 anos e
que o final está bom ter ficado aplicam
de vidro do de se estar a construir tudo
meu deus sca que sequer consegue fugir
dessa prisão de vídeo durante a minha
mãe sai de casa me tranco for leva
achava nunca mais saiu do nulo com mais
pra sempre esse filme o cara tá meu deus
como vou sair daqui é tudo verdade ele
falou vai aquecer o metal não sei quanto
graus centígrados e isso vai se mover
com alta qualidade só lá sistema solar
calculando a forma de pasta um potente
ataque dando vou ter ao ato de
nitrogênio líquido também que as pessoas
só estão almoçando após quem sabe até
saber a massa de novo sistema solar
ele se solta e só eu não deixasse preso
em casa do primeiro coisa que eu pensar
muito
e pelo menos comida né galera também tem
um som e sendo nós te domina o youtube é
ponte mais do limite às vezes ficam
necessidade você está acordado e se
desculpa fazer mas se eu pudesse cara
mil que a lei me ligou se 13 horas da
tarde todo mundo é china estava dormindo
porque eu moro em casa o humor sol e
morava em casa acordaram cedo que
precisam saber que tinha comigo não tem
21 índios para não acordar e ir lá fazer
comida depois eu acordar e ver o que
estão fazendo para comer então por ficar
domingo em erechim mas tem que acordar
que a potência não perde não vai pra
frente meu deus eu tenho honra no brasil
aonde eu sou meu deus o windows trabalho
sozinho minhas próprias leis um gângster
a gente às vezes durmo tanto que a única
ação que eu tenho no dia essa bank ó
mas nada de interessante
e pronto já sabe que é muito bom quando
a gente acorda quando a gente sente o
frio sem da banda eu sei que você sabe
que eu estou falando
sabe quando você babi que fica aquela
pocinho assim o cetac 2min mais fácil
você tem isso aqui se espanta abata
fiança
aí você só aparece aqui é esse eu não
sei que a galera já vou eu vou pelo
momento mas não vou entrar em estádios
um desastre não estão domingo 26 é bom
dormir às vezes fico pensando meu deus
se eu fosse um espermatozóide ainda
estava eu estava a dormir e tantos
problemas a oitava no auge da minha
juventude mesmo gigante mal times na
melhor não ver se ela é mas é que nós é
agora porque eu preciso do milho da
minha vida tá sem sentido não ser mais
difícil que no fim ao entrevistador me
pagava no fio fino fala isso gestão faz
de reflexão um casa de ferreiro tanto
bate até que fura o que você comentasse
aqui embaixo que você faria se o mundo
inteiro fosse ao contrário o que vocês
como antes
não sei a primeira vez está se é a
primeira vez que você está vendo essa
primeira vez está assistindo um vídeo
mil escreve no canal assistir a outros
vídeos em conjunto com os outros são
melhores hits a carta e pitt e cate é
não só maikai que tinha gente da light
que continuar fazendo tudo direito da
lapa continua a fazer todo dia até o fim
do mês
ss ajude você não vou conseguir às vezes
eu fico pensando que seria de mim sem
vocês eu sou só uma pessoa que anunciou
que está acontecendo quem sou eu para
julgar
muito obrigado você teve de se visitar
aqui quem quiser me seguir no twitter
que eu vou fazer um vídeo respondendo às
pessoas do twitter vamos seguir é esse
aqui tá na tela você me segue no twitter
o meia italiano também está natel você
vê vários foto legal na sua vida e vão
agregar muito que você vai ficar tão
feliz que vocês enquanto se lançava
muito obrigado aos amigos como todos
vocês beijo no coração imenso vácuo